-Thank you so much.
You look gorgeous.
So --
-Look, it's people.
-I know. There's people here!
isn't that great?!
-Hi!
-I know. It's the best.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks for being here in studio.
-I am so happy to be here.
-It means a lot to us,
so thank you.
We've crossed paths, but we've
never actually met before.
-Yeah.
I've seen from you afar a lot.
-And I'm always like, "Hi."
Because we have friends
in common, which, for me,
it's like third-degree
separation.
-Yeah.
-Like...
your favorite person ever,
Justin Timberlake,
who I worked with
and did a music video --
I was like,
"Okay, so, I know Justin,
so now I'm friends with Jimmy."
-Yeah.
-Because --
-Of course.
-It's like --
-Yeah. We're besties now.
-We're best friends.
I'm your favorite new Aquarius.
-Yeah, I will take that.
Yeah, I love that.
[ Applause ]
What was your plan?
'Cause I know you were
a big star in Latin America.
But did you plan on just coming
to the States and taking over?
-No. Never.
That was never a plan at all.
I was actually
just swinging by L.A.,
and I was just,
for random reasons, there.
And I rented --
this, like, lady --
before Airbnb existed,
like, an old lady's house
in the back,
and I was just staying there
and depressed.
And my mom was like, "Why
don't you go to an audition?"
I'm like,
"Mom, that's not how it works."
Like, I'm --
Imagine, if it was like --
Yeah,
I just to go to an audition,
become a Hollywood star.
It's, like, very hard.
I was like, "Yes, Mom."
She's like, "Oh, my God.
I heard about this thing
called IMDbPro.
I'm gonna sign you up.
It's fine."
I was like, "Sure, Mom."
So then, sure enough,
my mother sort of found a way
to get me an audition.
-See?
-And I go to this audition.
And I was terrified,
'cause English is
my second language,
and I was like --
never done this before.
So I, like, did it,
and I did another audition
and clearly didn't get it,
and then found out
it was "Star Wars."
[ Laughter ]
It was "The Force Awakens."
-Wow.
-And I had no idea.
But, then, I just moved back.
And then, at the time,
I had bought --
I don't know if you remember.
This was like 2007,
you guys, '08 --
where you have to
buy a flip phone at the 7-Eleven
'cause you couldn't get, like,
a phone on the store
if you were, like, from Mexico.
You needed, like, a -- all the
shebangs of being an American.
So I had this flip phone,
'cause I was texting
with this guy.
So that was the one thing
I got in L.A. -- had a hot boy.
So, I was in a bridal shoot.
This is wild.
-[ Laughs ]
-I was in the middle
of a bridal shoot
and, you know, big, big dresses,
just like today.
And I'm sitting there, and I
get a phone call, and I pick up.
And they're like,
"Is this Eiza González?"
I'm like, "Yeah. Who is this?"
"Mary Vernieu."
And I'm like,
"I don't know who you are."
-Mary Vernieu?
-She's a huge casting director
in Hollywood.
-Amazing, yeah.
-Massive.
-Legend.
-She's like,
"Can you tape yourself
right now?
I need it now."
And I'm like,
"I'm in a bridal shoot."
So I, like, took off my dress.
I have a dress on the bottom
like this big,
and I have a shirt.
And I taped against a wall
with a page.
And -- And, yeah,
then they called me.
They're like, "Can you fly in?
Robert Rodriguez
wants to meet you."
I was like, "Okay."
And then, the next day,
I was moving to Austin, Texas,
and I booked my first show.
Got the show,
didn't get the guy.
But, you know.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, no, I mean --
But look at you now, right?
Come on.
-Hi!
-In the number-one movie
in the country.
-He should have texted me back.
-Yeah.
You should've texted her back,
buddy.
She's in the number-one movie.
Come on. Yeah, exactly.
Let's talk about
"Godzilla vs. Kong."
-Yes.
-It is massive.
-Yeah.
-Globally massive.
How is it like to act
where there's like --
there's nothing
really real, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
Nothing's real.
Sorry, guys.
Godzilla does not exist.
Or Kong. I mean, he does --
in our imaginations.
-Yeah.
-But I was just terrified,
because, you know,
when you're doing these movies,
you don't really know
what you're gonna do.
And one of the first things
that happened to me
that I realized on the day
was that I have motion sickness.
-So, we were on set and, yeah,
I was in a thing called "HEAV."
And they strap you into it.
And I had four words to say --
no joke, guys -- four words.
And I'm like --
[ Retching ]
-No.
And then I'm like --
[ Retching ]
And then,
it was my birthday that day.
And the director's like,
"It's fine. You can do it."
I'm like, "Sure, sure."
And I'm nervous.
English is my second language.
I'm like, "I can do this.
This is five words.
I can do this."
Um, I couldn't.
I almost threw up.
It was my birthday,
and they're like, "Great.
We're gonna cut this scene
out of the movie,
but, come --
happy birthday!"
♪ Happy birthday ♪
And they pull like five cakes,
and I'm like...
[ Both retching ]
-I'm like...
-Like, "Don't
take the cake out of it."
What -- it's called the HEAV?
-It's a HEAV, yeah,
in the movie --
you have to watch the movie
to know what it is.
-Yeah. Did you get a chance
to see it in the theater or...?
-I did.
I watched it in a movie theater
by myself,
which is really exciting
because I'm that type of person
that likes to be very mindful
when I'm in the movie theater.
I don't talk.
And I was like, "Whoa! Wow!"
-[ Laughs ]
-"I'm alone!
I can scream."
I was just screaming
the whole time.
It is just definitely
a "pinch me" moment
when you're part
of those massive movies
and you have no idea
how it's gonna look like.
I did, however,
leaving the movie
wish I would have done it
on shrooms.
I was like, "This is wild."
[ Laughter ]
I need to do it all over again.
-Yeah.
-Okay, alright...
[ Laughter ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Eiza González
in "Godzilla vs. Kong."
Take a look.
[ Kong growls softly ]
-Wow. Who's the idiot
who came up with this idea?
[ Kong snarls ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-I'm Maia Simmons.
My father sent me.
I run point for Apex.
-Nathan Lind, mission chief.
[ Kong roaring ]
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Yeah, don't worry.
I'm just here to babysit.
[ Kong roaring ]
[ Metal clanging ]
The Hollow Earth Aerial Vehicles
are on their way to Antarctica
as we speak.
I know you people think
you're cutting-edge,
but these prototypes
we're loaning you
will make what you've been
flying look like used Miatas.
-I love Miatas.
[ Kong growling ]
-Forget about the price tag,
which is obscene, of course.
The antigravity engines alone
produce enough charge
to light up Vegas for a week.
[ Kong roars ]
-All members on the main deck.
-Feel free to be impressed.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Feel free to be impressed.
-Seriously.
-Eiza González, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Godzilla vs. Kong"
is in theaters
and streaming on HBO Max now.